[Music]
jamaica
blue velvet
[Music]
uh
[Music]
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway honestly
my mom won't say it but we're completely
broke
and the only thing that's left in our
name is this creepy old farmhouse our
grandfather left us in the middle of
nowhere
why'd you bring me up here entertainment
value
[Music]
what is that i don't know
[Music]
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate that has no fault lines
no fracking no loud music even is
shaking on a daily basis
hey remember that one summer we died on
our table
i found this in my living room killer
replica
a replica of what a ghost trap
[Music]
there hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30
years
new york in the 80s it's like the
walking dead
your dad never mentioned this to you
it's just my mom
[Applause]
[Music]
my grandfather died my mom says we're
just here to pick through the roblox
life
wait a minute
who are you
[Music]
call it
it lock
[Music]
call it karma
[Music]
i believe that everything happens for a
reason
come on darling
it has a gunner seat
[Music]
[Music]
you